what are the health risks that guys
should consider if they're thinking
about going on trt someone comes to you
and says hey man I'm whatever at an age
where I feel like this is something that
I want to do what should I be concerned
about what would you tell them
well it depends the context in which
they enter into that because again if
you don't actually need it and you get
on it you could be making yourself
less healthy if you're already perfectly
functioning top tier and you're just
doing it because wow you want to look
like liver king or some [ __ ] like I
don't know but if you don't if you do
need it and you're clinically deficient
you are and again not a non-medical
advice but in general you're going to be
more prone to things like cardiovascular
disease neurodegeneration Etc so it's
kind of like if you actually clinically
need something to then
say what is the downside to trt it's
like what is the downside of not being
on trt at that point potentially
that's the kind of how I would frame it
for the actual clinical utility of it in
a real deficient setting it's kind of
like what could you be staving off by
using it in a responsible way it's kind
of and again I think this is where like
Brian could come in and be educating and
actually say this is you know like he
knows why stuff is actually useful and
healthy or has actual utility in a
clinical setting but he very much you
know foregoes that because it just
doesn't uh
fit the well up the now it hadn't fit
the narrative essentially
would you be surprised if the volume of
drugs that it's likely that he's taken
wouldn't have taken a little bit of uh
time off his health span oh for sure
yeah it's definitely not conducive to
longevity
the bigger you are the more muscle you
have okay this is too vague of a
statement because I was about to say if
you have too much muscle
you're just gonna die quicker in general
humans who are bigger and have more
demands from their organs to support
their infrastructure are going to
live a shorter amount of time in general
like like a small tiny Asian woman is
probably going to outlive the Jack
brontosaurus human that's on a
bodybuilding stage every single time why
because of the stress and Taxation it
takes to support the demands of that
tissue so and also it depends how
regulating you are of things like blood
pressure are you letting it get out of
whack do you have a resting heart rate
of like is are you like borderline
tachycardia all the time with 100
resting heart rate and you're never
getting to sleep because you're so
jacked up on androgens or like whatever
like there are so many things that play
into it it's multifactorial for sure but
in general if you are just a and again
this isn't to say because there is
definitely a push in the longevity
Community to be protein deficient and be
as small as possible and be frail and
just live a terrible life but live to a
hundred plus like there needs to be a
happy medium in my opinion for a high
quality of life that's also trying to
live as long as possible with that high
quality because you're gonna die
eventually and do you want those years
to be you know frail like barely [ __ ]
functional in a chair probably not so
there's definitely a happy medium but in
general the uh the more you go super
physiologic the less healthy it is in
all areas is kind of the best way to put
it that's a really good take and I
totally know what you mean with regards
to the balance between longevity uh
amount of years and quality of those
um do you want to feel good perform well
be able to do a variety of tasks and be
able to live life to its fullest or do
you want to permanently be in this
ambient anxiety about whether or not
your oxalate level has gone through the
roof because you didn't eat the right
type of spinach this morning like
that is I think one of the concerns I I
dug into the longevity Community for a
long time and Dr David Sinclair has been
on twice and went to go meet him in
Harvard and it was just after he'd been
on Rogan and then I went to go and see
him in Boston the week after that he's
getting a lot of heat recently I've had
yeah people think he's coordinating with
the FDA to get nmn banned in the
supplement industry I think that's true
I haven't looked into this at all I
haven't looked into it enough but there
is pretty damning suggestive things that
don't look too favorable and are people
um
like attached to the access to nmn yeah
it's like I don't even know if it has
that much utility at the end of the day
but it's just the fact that these trying
to restrict people so then he can
benefit from interesting potentially
again yeah yeah allegedly I haven't I've
sold one headline about this and didn't
I haven't read it yet but it makes you
also wonder is it just because he's a
big name that then has monetary upside
now that automatically equals he's a
piece of [ __ ] because that's often when
people start making money off something
that they were otherwise just talking
about with seemingly no bias or
financial incentive Etc you know he's
very much been on many podcasts and made
it seem like you know I don't
necessarily recommend it it's just what
I do but it literally says uh when
people ask what nmn do you take and he's
like yeah like I don't have a
recommendation he actually ended up I
think starting to say Life by Nature was
the one that he began using after a
while something tells me the only reason
that he gave up any brand that he uses
was simply because he was sick of being
asked which brand it is that he used it
was like a [ __ ] take anything from me
yeah it's a wild and odd scenario that I
feel like the maybe not the exact same
but like huberman or Sinclair they often
find themselves in a weird situation
where they'll talk about something they
feel is promising but they're so
influential that it then Spurs people
trying to buy it as you would expect and
then when they ask it for his
recommendation he's like do I just tell
you a brand or are you gonna then think
I have some sort of like well also you
you're adding in I've done the due
diligence about Tanga Ali and fidojia
regressus let's say and I've looked at
the the data on the back end of that
you're gonna then ask me for a
supplement recommendation off the back
of that which now requires me to go and
do a whole [ __ ] ton more investigation
in order to see whether double words or
gorilla mode or like whatever it is is
like the optimal product for me to go
and take so I I understand the
hesitation around that but when I first
spoke to David and the longevity our
slash longevity Reddit was going off
it's a very passionate community in a
way that few others are and I wonder how
much of the longevity communities like
real
vehement
um Obsession and uh passion for it is
kind of like a denial of death thing
that
inbuilt into the longevity Community you
have to assume that there is a a large
minority maybe even more of people who
have found that as a techno-utopia
secular equivalent of trying to find
eternal life that you would have done
previously spiritually and if someone
comes in and says starts to either
criticize the community or restrict
their access to supplements that they
think is going to like get them to the
promised land they're going to respond
in kind yeah yeah it's like
if you designed something from scratch
like I how nmn came to be
you know it's just like a basic thing
that could be derived from like like for
example nicotinic acid or niacin or any
of these things that are very very
overlapping these are readily available
as supplements so I don't really know
how the hype behind nmn came to be if it
was just Sinclair or what but it's
definitely uh
I don't know it's uh problematic when
you know that the price of it is
probably going to be exorbitantly higher
than the supplement itself because it's
going to be from pharmaceutical
standards and prescribed to you and then
it's going to involve some hiked up
hiked up amount that it costs Etc and
um yeah like I can I can see why he's
getting backlash regardless even if he
feels like he deserves the monetary
upside and he doesn't want to publicly
say it like he might very much feel like
I'm the only created the hype [ __ ] you
guys I'm gonna capitalize on it what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
all right
[Music]